[Music]
honey bees are fascinating creatures for
a number of reasons their incredible
work ethic the sugary sweet syrup they
produce and their intricate social
structure but another reason is that
honey bees are in fact excellent
mathematicians scientists claim the tiny
insects can calculate angles and can
even comprehend the roundness of the
earth but there's particular
mathematical be genius behind the most
important aspect of honeybee life the
hive just like humans bees need food and
shelter to stay alive the hive is not
only the bee's home but doubles as a
place to store their honey since it's so
central to survival honey bees have to
perfect the hives architectural design
if you examine any piece of honeycomb
you'll see that it's constructed from
tightly packed hexagonal or six-sided
cells of all the possible designs
why do you honeybees choose this one to
understand you need to think like a bee
bees need a secure place for their
entire colony to live
similarly there needs to be a place
where their nectar can be stored and
ripened suitably until it turns into
honey
that means there's a need for some
serious space efficiency a good solution
is to build little storage units or
cells just big enough for Abby to fit
into which can also double as the
containers in which nectar is stored the
bees very own honey jars the next thing
is to decide what the little cells
should be made out of bees don't have
beaks or arms to pick up things but they
are capable of producing wax the thing
is producing it is a lot of hard work
bees have to consume eight ounces of
honey to produce just one ounce of wax
so they don't want to waste it so they
need a design that allows them to store
the largest possible amount of honey
using the least amount of wax what shape
does that imagining for a minute that
all bees had to attend architecture
Academy and go to math class let's say
they asked their geometry teacher what
shape would give us the most space to
store our honey but require the least
amount of wax and the geometry teacher
replied the shape that you're seeking is
the circle leaving the bees to return to
their
construction site and begin building
their honeycomb using circular cells
after a while some of them might have
noticed a problem with their design
small gaps between the cells
we can't even fit in there that's wasted
space they might have thought so
ignoring the geometry lesson and taking
matters into their own hands the bees
went back to the drawing board to
rethink their beehive design once
adjusted triangles we can use triangles
look they fit together perfectly
another bee suggested squares finally a
third beat piped up and said Pentagon's
don't seem to work but hexagons do we
want the one that will use the least
amount of wax and be able to store the
most amount of honey yes I think that's
the hexagon why it looks more like this
circle than the others but how do we
know for sure to find out the
industrious insect architects calculated
the areas of the triangle the square and
the hexagon and found that the hexagon
was in fact the shape that gave them the
most storage space they agreed on an
ideal size and return to work
the space efficient comb that is a bee's
trademark today is probably the result
of this trial and error but over long
periods of evolutionary history however
it paid off peek into any hive with your
protective goggles and netting on of
course and you'll see the end result a
beautiful compact honeycomb that any
architect would have been proud to
design
you